welcome back guys to on base in your
Bleacher Report app today
we got Mike Harris
2022 NL Rookie of the Year Mike what's
going on baby nothing much I'm just glad
to be here thanks for coming man thanks
for coming before we uh start talking
about that Rookie of the Year stuff and
all those things uh you tweeted
I don't know what day it was a little
bit ago oh yeah what was that because
you're going on here
oh no what was that for the fans want to
know
uh
hey I didn't think you was gonna see
that
uh I sees everything yeah honestly I
just ah there it is
I just feel like myself again I was
getting back in my grill so I tweeted
that
uh yeah getting back in your group yeah
what does that mean
I'm starting to find my swing again
after this there we go okay now they're
looking
to bring it out a little confidence
anything yeah yeah yeah yeah so I'm
it's kind of manifesting okay all right
all right we're gonna get some get into
that but before we get into that I'd
like to play a game you know the name of
the show was on base until we have a
game where we always start out with
called uh on base off base you're in or
out right you know about that so the
first thing I want to ask is about big
hats are you in or out on big hats
I mean it grew on me I I was I was on
base so you you weren't now you're off
they took it away so I mean I didn't
mean you're off base on it no I'm on
this you're still on I'm on so why did
they take it away what was the theory
behind that it was uh I thought it was
pretty pretty cool yeah it was New Era
it was uh I guess we couldn't we
couldn't wear it because it was a uh it
kind of looked like a a new Arrowhead
and you didn't have their logo I get it
though they gotta do what they got to do
man so so now what's what's the new do
you have another one yeah I have another
one we just got regular high fives yeah
yeah but that's what we do so what about
this I got I got and I'm
totally on base on this Magic City Wings
I mean from what I've heard yeah I
haven't no oh my gosh you've never
you're you you're in Atlanta from
Atlanta
play for Atlanta and they had their
wings I think it's nothing but trouble
with Magic City so I'm gonna stay away
from it but this ain't we not talking
about that we talk about the wings you
don't walk in Magic City just for well
some people
there's a lot of things going on around
the wings so there are a lot of things
so
I'm gonna take you one day we're gonna
go eat some wings out all right all
right all right we're gonna make it
happen what about country music are you
in and out of country music I know I
love country music love country music
yeah I got my own playlist uh who's look
give me a hardest a couple artists in
your playlist
my favorite Jason Aldean uh so you go to
Jason Aldean concert oh yeah
oh yeah for sure I mean that says a lot
about you Mike I'm a very diverse I like
yeah I like all types of uh music so
yeah so so who else Aldine who else
Chris Stapleton oh so you you country
yeah I'm in there you are coming in
there yeah good for you good for you
what about what about Migos has more
hits than little baby who why are you in
or out on that
I think that's true yeah I mean they've
been out longer and
yeah first I don't know how I feel about
that yet
they I think they have more
more known hits more I guess Universal
Universal maybe I I don't I don't know
well it doesn't matter they have a lot
of you're in on that though yeah yeah
what about uh so you're a sports fan
from Atlanta to any other what about uh
like
the hall you watch the Hawks of course
what about uh Trey young you enter out
on Trey young I'm on base
I think yeah I think he's cold he's
pretty good yeah a couple pieces away
yeah that's what I think yeah this year
was good they've been they've been good
so do you how often do you go to games
uh I think I went I went twice
two or three times this off season so
NDC core side
maybe yeah yeah with the glasses and
everything huh you hard when you walk in
you guys
you you you you like man I'm gonna walk
in with a straight face like I'm hard I
want everybody looking at you yeah I
mean I didn't I didn't really nah but I
am Courtside sometimes
all right so let's talk about the
nickname Money Mike man where'd that
come from
uh it actually came from a coach okay I
guess I would come up in in clutch
situations and kind of just like get the
job done or whatever but uh yeah I mean
ever since then I stuck with me I made
in my username on like Twitter and I
guess once I got called up uh praise
fans really kind of uh brought it out
and made it a bigger thing
all right I like it I think it's
horrible I think it's hard so let's go
back to Young Money Mike
you you play baseball obviously what
other sports did you play
pretty much everything everything
basketball what was your favorite one
other than other baseball yeah baseball
I wasn't my favorite sport really I did
baseball kind of fell in my lap
everybody knows I was hooping during the
summer okay yeah see I was skipping
baseball tournaments to go who
and you know I I just ended up being
good enough at baseball to get drafted
or whatever but yeah but yeah and I like
so so yeah what's your favorite one
probably basketball but I wish I would
have started Golf when I was younger now
that I'm playing now golf I wish I wish
I wish I would have started Golf too
golf is like you gotta play golf yeah
but the thing with basketball I couldn't
I couldn't do it as a as a career
because I only uh shoot from a half
court so I'm not you only shoot from
half court yeah I get you a rebound dish
it out and I'm shooting half court when
you bring when you come back down what's
your theory behind the half court shots
oh I just shoot that's a shooter shoot
you a Steph Curry before Steph Curry
before okay yeah half course shots was
they going in though oh yeah shooting
half course shots getting uh getting all
rebound you wasn't going on and getting
rebounds I don't like going inside the
two three point Club yeah I mean I get
some rebounds and and dish it out to you
but I'm not gonna be the long rebounds
no no I will go down there too yeah but
I'm not going up for a layup and
contested is that because you were
scared to get hurt or something like
that that's injuries and I guess in high
school you know a lot of football
players try to play basketball so yeah
you get yeah you're just in there
tackling with shoulders and support
things yeah shaking my head so what
about this so you you you
wanted to be a veterinarian I heard that
through the great Grapevine what what
kind of animals did you have growing up
none no animals you have no experience
with animals yet you want to work on
them no I had a lot of friends that had
like
dogs or whatever and I what'd you say
something no I fell in love with a lot
of dogs and I guess that's why I like I
wanted to be a vet because I I like it
so so was it like that on just dogs or
all animals no like all house house pets
I guess so you you would snakes and
everything you like it all snakes I mean
I guess yeah you wouldn't really work on
snakes as much I don't think but yeah
you don't take the snake to the vet I
don't know I don't know I mean how do
you know something wrong with the snake
though I can't answer that yeah you
supposed to be the vet you know nah see
I didn't look that far into snakes
because I was doing just regular
irregular just domestic yeah
okay so so then you're playing ball I
used to come to East Cobb all the time
that was my stomping grounds so I'm
assuming you played a whole lot of East
Cobb as well how was that like how when
I started East Copper East cop Astros
that was the team yeah yeah the Astros
and I'm like oh every time we had to
play the Astros we got waxed yeah you
know what I'm saying and I don't even
know who all I played against but but
who was it who was who was the East car
team as you were coming up
who were they yeah
who was the team the teams that like
okay in these cars because it was the
Astro any team you know what I'm saying
like of course yeah he's got Astros but
like every year they would well every
tournament they would add a new player
so you don't know you don't know what
you're getting and you didn't want to
play with them play with them yeah I did
it for a year oh okay okay I left after
that yeah you left after that and then
where'd you go did you did you still
stay with teams here in Georgia or did
you kind of move around and play with
other teams from other other states no
it was it was teams in Georgia but it
was like not in the Atlanta area it was
y'all went everywhere yeah yeah still
playing tournaments did you ever go out
west
it's all the best tournaments were here
so okay so then you're playing ball
through through uh high school and you
get recruited
um by LSU to be just a pitcher right
how was that bro like you enjoyed you
you enjoy pitching like that
like that was or is that just something
you were just good at
yeah I did I did love pitching but I
also wanted to to hit so yeah uh once
they just offered for pitch and I kind
of ruled him out they were my dream
school too so oh dream school yeah
missed out on money Mike yeah if they
would have gave me the two way maybe I
would have maybe I would have signed
there these do you talk to the coaches
now no oh you don't talk to none of them
no wait which coaches yeah other coaches
yeah they recruited you no no so I had a
situation I wanted to go to Kentucky
and that was like my dream School
Kentucky
and I talked to the coaches a couple
times you know when you can get the call
yeah and uh call them or they called me
and we talked and I thought it was all
great you know what I'm saying and then
and then as I was going through my
senior year whatever I just stopped
hearing from them yeah
and uh they said they had a recruiting
class the year prior and they didn't
really need me anymore which I
understand but they didn't call me until
I got made they didn't call me back I
didn't talk to them until I made it back
to the I meant I made it to the big
leagues so I got a random call one day
and it was a coaching he kind of told me
how it played out so I didn't know if
that kind of happened to you you know
with uh with them like did they
apologize because look at you now bro no
I mean it happened I mean I don't I
haven't talked to him since so so so
okay you got drafted end up signing
going through the minor leagues tell me
about the minor leagues bro how did you
enjoy it
honestly I kind of did uh you know how
everybody tells you it was like a grind
down there you didn't grind at all I
mean I grind it but I guess I was having
some good success so it didn't feel like
I feel like a grinding I was you shot
through the mileage just playing free uh
kinda I mean we didn't have the season
in 2020 so right uh I guess that that
kind of I guess that kind of helped a
little bit though right so yeah because
we had the alternate side so I was a I
was 19 up at the alternate site with the
AAA and Big League guys so just playing
them every day and then you beat how was
it being around those guys like being
young
oh yeah it was
um it was cool because that was that
that was that same year that I think we
lost to y'all and the in the playoffs
and
um that was a that was a good team so to
have a lot of those guys come up and
down and be able to face them it was It
was kind of cool like I feel like I
learned more yeah dude that that really
helped you uh mature faster you think
yeah I felt like it was better than
actually having a a season because I
probably would have started in low a so
probably wouldn't have seen all the
talent that I did there so so you get
you and then in double A you only play
like 40 games
then got called up right like 50 yeah
yeah 50 games got called up so when you
got called up and you you called your
mama what'd you say
yeah first I called my dad oh called
pops okay what do you say I I called him
and added my mom's her car but I didn't
know they were like right next to each
other in the bed at the time yep so
they're both on the phone and uh
I call him and just asking if they can
pick me up from the airport tomorrow
then didn't even didn't even say why and
they just said okay no my dad was like
stop playing oh really yeah
um
and they so my mom's like you going to
Gwinnett I was like nah
I'm actually going to hire so they they
start freaking out of course my mom
calls everybody that she knows and it's
like a bunch of people at the game the
next day I don't know how because it was
a it was a day game I don't know how she
had enough time when I called her at
anything 11 or 12 at night it's your
mama yeah baby made it yeah I don't
think they got some that any sleep that
night
barely yeah I had to go out and face
Sandy too so um
yeah it is what it is though yeah so so
you on that day like it was a day game
so you really that happened fast so you
really didn't even like have good time
to really soak in it like soak in BP and
all those type of things
yeah I mean I'm probably not on a day
game oh yeah sure so so your family was
there were you nervous
what were you more nervous for like
hitting or or defense
it was really just getting the first
step out of the way after I got the
first step back that's the way I felt
fine because
I mean it's still the same game same
baseball also I was I was way more
nervous to play defense than I was to
hit really yeah cause hitting is like
it's I mean some of us kind of look like
you gotta hit it where nobody is you
know what I'm saying that's kind of hard
to do right
um but when those guys make pitches you
got to catch the ball and I I was fresh
into the outfit at that point so I was
if they hit me in Fly ball
legs shaking everything's shaking man so
okay so
one Rookie of the Year how was that like
how was how was having all that type of
success that was I mean that was crazy I
mean I'm just to think about I was in
double A to start the year thought I
would at least stop by AAA but
call me up and then after that
just went on to play play my game and
and kind of like just do what I do so I
guess it all just
oh the pieces fell in the right spot and
I guess I won so when you when you
we're having the success in one Rook of
the year were you like
man this is like
it's the big leagues but it's kind of
easy like it's kind of easy you know
what I'm saying well did that ever did
that ever come in your mind
no I wouldn't say it was easy I mean I
guess I was just
I was just doing what I knew I could do
yeah yeah everything was just flowing
um
having fun yeah winning games so I guess
yeah it made it all easier winning games
and yeah winning always makes everything
yeah so now this year you guys are
playing well per usual
and this is your sophomore year and
typically this is the time and I know
for me I can speak from my experience
like this is the time when I started to
fail and and it's hard yeah it gets hard
because you just went through success
you bought all the minor leagues then
you start balling the big leagues and
then the league starts to to just figure
out figure you out
and the game is Just harder in general
where everybody's all the pictures are
coming up throwing 98 and so
um you know I remember ah Leah I don't
know I tried to do what I'm doing last
year and it's not really working and I'm
not really understanding the adjustments
that need to be made and and so how are
you how are you going to continue the
success that you had from your year
because I had to learn like I gotta
study yeah and I gotta you know work on
my mechanics I I gotta think along with
the pictures and think along through the
situations of the whole game like how
have you learned that
or what have you learned
I mean I feel like it's it's harder
right now for me because I I just came
up the the two injuries or whatever in
my back and then my knee so I can't I
think that kind of affected affected my
swing for a while but yeah that's what I
made the I guess that's what I made the
Tweet because I'm starting to finally
feel my swinging and getting right back
in this uh how I felt last year and so
it's just that that's that money Mike he
a problem huh uh he can't I mean you put
that that tweet up it's got the you you
got to know something coming yeah he can
be a problem you just
yeah we gotta wait and see yeah we gotta
wait and see okay so do you do you keep
up with do you watch like the other the
other
uh like the West Coast should I say
because from us we're watching you guys
yeah so do y'all watch us like after
your after your game like do y'all watch
do you watch baseball at all yeah I mean
y'all are like the only team still
playing because the West so I guess when
we're having our bus rides at the
airport or something or so you're
keeping up with the league
yeah I like to keep up so who who give
me some rookies this year that you've
seen that have been like oh I think he's
really good like here's some of your
peers
um Corbin Carroll out man yep
um
damn
uh
did you play with any of these guys
I played against Coral I mean again
against against yeah I played against
him in a travel ball he had two home
runs against us so oh so you know him
for a little while then yeah he's been
doing that and so you said outman and
and you know I have my own personal
opinion but why do you think I'm good I
mean
I mean I feel like there's just no
pressure on him and he can he can kind
of play free and he's been doing that
he's having some sick we have a really
good a really good roster and like you
said something always helps yeah my my
thoughts on outman is is not even
baseball related it's just how he
handles himself right I think he handles
himself like a professional and that's
why he's always going to be good so if
he works hard he does every all those
things but like when things aren't going
great yeah you can't tell
about him and really I think good
players in general you know what I'm
saying like just how they carry
themselves there's like a little
confidence in those type of things that
uh you just gotta
exude right yeah nice work okay so and
uh in in August last year you signed an
extension how was that process like uh
because you see this money on a sheet of
paper
it's hard to say no
you know what I'm saying and y'all got
came to terms and congratulations thank
you so how was it
uh it was kind of it's kind of crazy it
was only a month into the season yeah it
was quick I got to yeah start the
conversation with that and
um honestly after I signed it I would
always forget that I actually did sign
it during the season
um I would just have random times in the
Outfield because you're out there
thinking an outfit nobody to talk to so
I actually had a couple times where I'm
like dang I really I really just signed
this deal in in the state that I grew up
in and team are rooted for so yeah it
was It was kind of it was kind of crazy
and
honestly I still forget about it now
because I'm just out there playing the
game I've been playing and forget that
it's actually my job so are you still
like what was the first thing you bought
when you when you signed the bill
nothing I mean you didn't buy anything
no I mean or no car no house no necklace
no shoes I already had my car so it was
like so you don't really spend money you
didn't you didn't buy your mama Nothing
by pops nothing and that's cool if you
didn't oh for Christmas I did I paid the
mortgage off but oh nice okay okay so
you and that you do nothing with your
boys yeah I mean obviously didn't go to
magic he didn't get no wings so so you
know I'm saying what what did you do
nothing nothing
I mean I just do nothing I just I just
golf I Gotta Buy golf balls so I got to
save my money because
so you sign the eight year extension for
golf balls it could be you ain't getting
no clubs
I already have
you ain't getting anything
I don't have to buy them okay all right
you know what I guess not yeah because
you money might no you money Mike Money
Mike don't buy golf club right I guess
okay so let me ask this since you play
golf you've been watching do you watch
do you watch the uh all the tournaments
and whatnot give me give me give me your
foursome a foursome that you would love
you would dream to play with
including you so I guess three people so
three
it's good you know
I say tiger Rory and
John Ron tiger Rory and Jama you know
you could you can actually make that
happen that's not even like a dream one
bro come on yeah you can make your money
Mike I don't have those I don't I don't
have that type of home runs I bet you
can make a couple calls all right you
know what I'm saying you make a call
that can happen all right so I I'm gonna
go tiger for sure but I want to play I
would want to play with like Jack
Nicholas and Arnold Palmer because I
want to see like
you know the the older days how they
played yeah golf because you know it's
not the same technology is not was not
the same yeah
and so so how often do you play Go
you know season I was going
at least maybe at least two times a week
two times a week yeah so and do you
remember somewhere
nah that's when you go next do you just
play with random people or do you always
go with people you know no I always go
with people I know I feel like I can't
nah can't do 18 holes with random people
so no you think it's hard
but in Nashville
I am a member of the club and before I
became a member of the club I would go
to
um
public courses and I would just get a
random tea time and I met a lot of
people and it taught me how to talk to
people
so just I'm not and I'm not even
recommending that you do that now but
I'm just saying no it makes sense you
know it just teaches you different
because you don't know who you're paired
with right right and that's why I feel
like I can go talk to Seinfeld yeah
because I've played golf golf has taught
me so much about like
so I learned a lot on the golf course
you learn a lot on the golf course so I
want my daughter to play go and my son I
want my kids to play golf as well I'm
I'm trying to insert a golf club in
their hand as much as I can so
so last season you know you were sparked
for Atlanta and and how what is it like
being around just a winning organization
like that because I think people don't
understand
because other organizations aren't like
that right and so then maybe because
it's all you know but like what is it
like being showing up and you know that
your team is gonna have a chance to win
every uh every day
um the organization cares they're going
to try and get the pieces or whatever it
takes to help you like what is how does
that appeal when you walk into the
clubhouse I think it just it just makes
you play uh have more fun and and I
guess play looser because
May everybody around you has the ability
to to go out and I guess play their play
at their Highest Potential and and
affect the team in a good way so
um just having just having everybody on
the team uh be able to do that and yeah
have fun yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
got a good group of guys yeah I think
that's the best thing about the team
honestly
um not even not even the skill set it's
just everybody everybody can talk to
each other and go on a different ways
they spend more time with them than
anybody else exactly so yeah
you know all day every day really yeah
and so and so do y'all have like any uh
but you know what what's she like a
routine for you give you like a routine
a routine day for Money Mike you wake up
in the morning put the shades on hat
backwards and then whatever
[Music]
I don't know uh get up probably be on my
phone be on Tick Tock for a little bit
just to just to wake my body up um it's
a tick tock wake you up
yeah okay got some got some funny videos
on my for you page so um
I don't really do much before the game I
think you just chill yeah chill and then
go to the field I remember them days
yeah I at least sleep till 12 o'clock oh
yeah I'm sleeping in man if I slept past
9 30 now I feel like I missed the days
done
yeah but I got two kids
I got a wife at home I got you know the
certain responsibilities so yeah like I
came really 10 o'clock is about as as
far as I can go and then yeah I'm I'm
that's why you said Tick Tock wakes you
up I got people jumping on my face you
know what I'm saying but it is what it
is you'll get you'll get there at some
point so you don't have what about your
routine on the road tell me something
about on the road you have a routine
that you go through
[Music]
um
same thing so who packs your bag
me you pack your bag yeah okay so when
you go to pack your bag how do you pack
it do you pack it in outfits or do you
just throw jeans in there some shirts in
there some shoes in there I definitely
pack your body outfits so how if you
have a six game Road Trip that's tough
ah
so I packed so we have six games
I packed four maybe five outfits because
we have on travel days we have the extra
one in there just in case y'all go do
something
yeah that's I think that's the fifth one
that's the fifth that's the fifth one
yeah maybe maybe even throwing the extra
the sixth one but uh travel days where
like our our jobs
right there so so
do you eat good on the road like do you
just only eat at the stadium
uh when we so the hotels we stay in we
uh we actually have breakfast like for
breakfast oh yeah I got a team breakfast
yeah every day yeah okay so you got team
breakfast every day so you eat eat the
team breakfast yeah and then do you like
it is the food always good yeah I'm
basic I just go eat breakfast bacon okay
so so and then
you just eat it so you don't you don't
pay for any meals you don't you don't do
you care about how you eat do you care
about any of that are you young so I
mean back then I didn't I mean yeah to a
certain extent yeah I'm not just gonna
be out here eating eating the worst
things every day but I mean as I gotten
older man you know I uh
you'll learn this little little tricks
of the trade I'm gonna show you this
because it'd be 60 70 80 or a waffle and
some bacon and so can we roll the roll
the video please this is how I roll this
is how Mook pull up you know what I'm
saying
I used to be a chef back in the day I
wanted to be a chef when I was young no
way yep so that's how I eat man you know
what I'm saying I and then I I order
groceries
and then I cook my food
you know what I'm saying where do you
get eighty dollar waffles and bacon from
uh these these Hotel bro they're they're
they're oh you order them yeah oh okay
yeah I mean the whole like we have the I
mean we stay at a five-star hotel and
you know if you don't order a lot
they gonna tax you you know you want
some water it's gonna be twenty dollars
and so and so here we got the burners
you know and then we got all the
utensils the spray the oil you know when
I make breakfast I got jelly in there
you know what I'm saying the knife
peanut butter
um so when I'm hungry at night I can
make me a little PB and J I try to try
and eat really good man because you know
I got 10 more years in this thing so I'm
gonna be 40 when I when I you know I got
to make sure I still can move around and
do this but yeah man that like whenever
you ready you know I'm a pet me whenever
whenever you ready or travel travel
kitchen travel kitchen stuff and and and
and and and
I think this is going to be the next the
next wave you know what I'm saying and
so I have my chef my chef James actually
is
um the one responsible for this um yeah
because I had to gain weight so I got I
was small I went vegan for a little bit
got small
then I got hurt and I was down like 10
pounds and so this is a
my way of gaining my weight back in and
you know I'm saying do what I doing what
I need to do so I can yeah money move
I'm gonna tell you
um so so so
being black in baseball obviously that's
the thing right
um how have you handled it is it is it
is it rough is there are there parts of
things that you didn't know or or
responsibilities that you didn't know
that now you know being a big leader no
I mean it's been it's been pretty cool
the same same yeah always
I don't know I was never
yeah I mean for me for me for me it's
like
you know
there's there's not very many of us in
the game and so I take the
responsibility of okay I have to throw
the game in our with culture in the
Black Culture yeah and it's hard to do
it's hard to do because you know we're
the minority right and I just didn't
know if if
view felt that there was something that
you learned as you've gotten here in in
and you're in Atlanta too so you really
you have you have a real deal backing
you know in L.A and there's people in
L.A there's like but you're in Atlanta
yeah that's what I was going to say
being in Atlanta that's a lot of it's a
lot of black kids that still play the
game and want to I mean I guess do you
go out and see those kids or do like
little camps with the kids and all those
other things yeah yeah and I guess it's
kind of my job to I guess help to grow
the game for them and show them that I
guess it's it's possible how do you do
what's a way for you to do it just me
being me I guess me being me and just
going out there and I mean I guess
interacting with them uh
I guess that means signing the ball
having a conversation uh and when you
have these kind of did you have to learn
how to talk to kids
I I had it I was terrible at talking to
kid first because I just didn't know how
to talk to them yeah you know like
they're a lot of times they're in awe
because you money Mike yeah so they
can't say anything you know what I'm
saying and so
you didn't have to learn it was easy for
you
I mean I guess I'm still learning but
the more I guess the more I meet it just
gradually the gradually get better it
gets easier yeah yeah it gets easier
just to hold a conversation what about
the parents like talking to parents and
have people ask you for tips and advice
you know how do you how do you handle
that type of stuff
I think that's pretty that's the easier
part I mean they're adults so you know
you've been talking to adults for I
guess pretty much
it's easier and I guess they understand
more so I had I had a bad time with all
that maybe I maybe everything just easy
for Money Mike no no no I had a hard
time like people asking me tips and I'm
like I don't really know like this
baseball thing just kind of fell on me
and now I understand it but I can give
them Basics but if they want to go into
depth I don't really know I just I just
do it it just kind of happens right yeah
yeah yeah and so and so have you had uh
have you had any like random cousins
come out the woodwork
because that's the thing
um
I don't know
nobody I don't know so everything's just
been smooth for Money Mike man
no drama you just you know everything's
been good for you no that's good though
just try to stay out of the drama it's
good yeah it's good stay out the way
yeah you got what you needed to do and
and now you just stay out the way stay
out of trouble
boring is always boring is good remember
that love it foreign
that's me you know what I'm saying yeah
so do you have money Mike on your golf
ball I've had some but I lost them
yeah I didn't buy him oh you don't buy
the golf ball with me no I do but they
were giving to me the money like you
don't want it you don't you don't want
to get them all I can get some more but
it's like if I'm gonna lose them I'm
gonna wait till like not losing this
minute yeah I feel you gotta wait till
you get good
so so that
as you last year rookie or whatever who
who did you lean on a lot for like
advice and how to get through certain
things you're still young so there's
still a lot of things that you could
you can learn and we'll learn but like
who was it who's like a mentor for you
or or a example that you that you look
up to I think the main guy was uh Dansby
he was he was big on um I guess giving
us giving us your guys information and I
guess the different ways to go about the
game and and how to play it certain
situations what to do I mean what what
certain people like what they don't like
and I guess how to carry yourself is he
is he used to talk to him
no I mean I talked to him in the off
season and yeah I meant to I was gonna I
was gonna talk to him uh pretty soon but
yeah I talked to him a good bit in the
off season so who who's like the leader
for y'all now
everybody apparently we just I guess
we're just a collective Collective uh
group of leaders I got a good good group
of vets over there too but you who do
you talk to like who do you learn that
stuff from now because you gotta you
need someone someone to talk to about
that I mean I say ocean also yeah he's
the man that guy for me now and he and
this is his first year
second year second year second year so
second year so he he come in and
immediately
like has become like a a leader slash
whatever yeah and he is he a outspoken
guy I haven't really got to meet him in
jail yeah I mean I met him obviously you
know playing but I don't know his
Personality yeah a lot of people think
he doesn't really have one but in the
clubhouse he's a he's a pretty funny guy
he got he's a sarcastic guy too so he he
does he he talk does he talk I'll talk a
lot or is he kind of like just kind of
states to himself I want to say a lot I
mean
he talks I guess when normal yeah yeah
yeah so he so what about like trap like
Darnell
saying he's funny he's funny too so I
play with his brother yeah and I love
them yeah
so so y'all got so what about uh snit
snit's great I had him in the All-Star
Game
and I really understand why
on top of the players yeah but like
while the Braves are really good because
snitt is a really good manager he's
managing the game is hard to do like
yeah so have you have you learned
anything from Sid has he talked to you
about anything I mean he's he's pretty
laid back so he doesn't really I guess
say anything until needed but it just
lets us go out there and play uh so who
who kind of governs the team
when I say Governor's a team like uh
if you were were like whatever your
Unwritten rules are or not they could be
written with whatever rules yet you guys
abide by as a team like who kind of runs
that yeah
I mean he'll tell us when yeah like
if we do something then I guess it's not
something that's a good look for us
he'll let us know but I mean for the
most part nobody really nobody on our
team really does that uh so you guys you
just got a good group of guys yeah and
so and so what about okay
now let me get to this
you you you you you try disrespecting me
and I don't really like that
um
when it comes to bowling you know what
I'm saying that's disrespectful to you
that's my life and
um
you did come to my event so thank you
for that you and Lucas yeah
um but but how did you get into bowling
I want to know that let me know how you
got on the phone before I start talking
watch it so
um I was
whenever I went bowling like as a kid I
would always
be the guy to spin it spin the house
ball or whatever look at everything oh
nice there you go right there I'll be
together spin the House Bar yeah make it
come back so I never I never really got
a ball until
I guess when covet when Kobe hit that's
when I got my first two he was bored
not bored but like you know what I'm
just gonna go bowling a lot more that
more often nah I mean I always I always
wanted in my high school but I just I
just never bought them I mean I guess oh
now that I'm drafted I got them I guess
the money whatever so so you went and
got some got a couple a couple balls or
just one I got two couple balls drilled
and now
look at that between the legs I'm I
I'mma give it like a a
imma give it a
I mean
look at you you think you guys well let
me see though I I want to see the harder
ones
I'm gonna give it a hey I'm gonna give
it a if if you're a bowler if you're
bowler you have probably done something
similar to that I don't you know what
I'm saying you got to go to backwards
the granny style you got to do all I've
done the uh like 360 between the legs
yeah then I would have gave that one to
ten I mean that was just basic though
that's that's the basic one I ain't want
to say that I ain't want to dog you like
that but yeah that's that's the basic
one you know what I'm saying so so you
gotta you you do you you folks both
uh my mom did but I've never seen my dad
touch a bowling ball have you both have
you bought any tournaments or anything
no I wanted to but
um yeah me and me uh grip we wanted to
uh he has but you know it's kind of like
a
it's like over a Course once a month so
we didn't really commit to it he would
like fill in for it for a guy yep but
yeah uh we wanted to be in one but there
weren't there weren't any that were like
I guess uh short short term so do you
don't like in the off season you don't
do like an elite a league or anything
because I I come to Atlanta ball
Atlanta is huge and so you a bowler well
you you thank you I'm saying thank you I
do I do want to I appreciate you for
coming to my event but next time you
come to my event we're gonna get
me verse you
know okay and we're gonna get cameras
right there all right and I'm gonna show
you
I'm a dog see but do I get do I get some
pins or is it just just straight up
straight up
I don't really need no pins you got like
25 300 games you said uh oh with the
with the with the uh Emoji you know what
I'm saying so you you hot you ready you
ready for anything at this point all
right then we got to do just trick shots
then nah I got you while we came to the
bowler regular game you know what we can
do a regular game and then we can all
right shots You Gotta Give me Advantage
too because you've been yeah you're
right you're right
you drew your own boss
so you might be doing some something
Shady no I ain't gonna do nothing shady
I ain't gonna doggy like that but but
we're gonna we're gonna set it up it's
all right deal we can we can put
something on it since you ain't spent no
money you know what I'm saying maybe I
can dip into that a little bit maybe all
right you know oh yeah you make sure you
like it okay so look listen
we uh yesterday we put up on our
Bleacher Report happiness story that uh
some questions so I want to ask ask you
some questions from the fans right sure
outside of your own teams who do you
think is the most exciting player slash
players in baseball and this is for both
of us
I can give you mine yeah I'll give you
I'll let you uh talk right now kunya
I can say that you can't say that I know
I know yes a lot of it's a lot of
different players you can go with
um for sure a ton wait tatis is always
exciting yeah to watch
um
every time I get a question like this I
can't think of players anymore yeah I
can't I don't know um
I don't even know how I can't even think
of all the people whenever somebody
asked me about players I don't remember
them anymore
I really enjoy watching
you know those are all the exciting
people right
but the people that I really really
enjoy watching are like the gold
Schmidts the Arenado yeah the Mike
trouts yeah you know they're consistent
it's really like the people that kind of
they've been on top of the world yeah
and now they're just kind of going and
you know everybody's looking for the
next
you know Splash yeah did you classify
for that I don't know man I I don't be
doing nothing I don't be doing that let
me hear your people though I want to
hear your people I'll go with Tony
um
like I said I can't
obviously tatis electric
um
I don't know I have to say it come here
just because I can't yeah I said I'm
gonna say it just because I can't
um
that's good though I mean that's good
like those are the main people that's
that and and you know there's polar bear
Pete he's he plays with a lot of emotion
you know what I'm saying so
um his game looks a little differently
yeah than those guys obviously but I
like the emotion the passion that he
really plays with as well um I gotta get
in play with him on the WB in the WBC
you really felt it you know you really
you really really felt this so I got
another question if you were to face one
legendary pitcher who would it be
Randy Johnson just to see how hard it
was to hit him
I don't know if I want to pay for
anything I feel like he will heal throw
a neck ball and it's over with after
that but I understand I understand Randy
Johnson you know how I think I would
want to face like Satchel Page
um
because I just want to see what it
looked like yeah you know what I'm
saying
that makes sense you know that and you
know they say he threw hard you know I
don't know you know I yeah I would love
to see it but you said Randy Johnson
went yeah good for you no I wasn't going
to dessert I wasn't going in the box
with the intention to get hit it was
just just see yeah it was like this VR
man nah
that's not the same all right so give me
give me give me what is your ideal
bowling look
and or if you
what were your ideal bowling shirt look
like
if I was to make a bowling shirt
it would probably have a dollar sign
nah I don't even think about that I
might do that now money like that yeah
um
I think it would have been like a little
little you know what I'm saying little
cotton t-shirt
nah I think I would have went with the
old school or bowling bowling shirt
Jersey yeah with the collar yeah yeah
but and then I guess throw a nickname on
the back
yeah another nickname yeah I mean yeah I
mean I I can't go against it now yeah
you gotta embrace it you're all in on
that yeah you got to embrace that now
yeah I wouldn't have I wouldn't have
thought about the dollar but maybe
dollars maybe bro and yeah the dollar
would be hard I think you should be and
then and then put your face in there and
you can't put like a little you gotta
put like a nice picture in there you
hard you know what I'm saying like
probably probably right before you walk
into the Hawks game you know what I'm
saying right when you got that face on
you know you walk in Your Heart Take a
picture then and put that one on there
all right I got another question for you
last question
do you think uh this person says is this
an NLCS preview two best teams in
baseball
between us
I think I mean yeah I feel like we're
sort of
two of the top teams in NL yes yeah I
say it's exciting every time we play
each other so yeah it's always fun and I
think I think it could be but a lot of
times when it gets to playoffs it's just
about like
it's just about like who gets hot yeah
because anybody anybody can get high
anybody can get hot and anybody can play
and and that's really what playoffs is
and it's about riding
the momentum yeah it's got nothing to do
with the regular season at that point
right and so so as you as you've as you
play as you play Mike what's what's the
the first thing that you learned that
you had to stick to like you know what
because it's mine I'll tell you mine
mine was I had to learn to believe in
myself
because when I started it started to
fail and even now even now
like when I'm not playing well going
through the slumps
I had I had to really truly learn to
believe in myself and believe in my
abilities and so I want to know one
thing that
you had to like
mine was just always be myself because I
guess when I try to
when I try to get out of that and try to
be somebody else be like somebody else I
kind of tend to
I don't know struggle and not be what
I've been so how do you how does that
happen though how do you how do you
forget to how do you how do you you know
what I'm saying
um is it just from a little bit of
like going through a slump that makes
you question it or is it something that
maybe someone hit a home run and it's
like you know what I wanna I wanna hit
balls like that like what what is it
that makes you questionable I think it's
a mix of both of those things I mean
just
playing against playing against a lot of
good players you see see them have
success and you kind of wanna
do something they're doing and it's not
for you and you kind of you kind of step
out of your
your comfort zone and try to be
different to have some different results
but
yeah I guess you are who you are bro yes
just just be you and you are in your
game so money might learn just be you
man yeah just be you be Money Mike be
Money Mike all right man well it's good
to have you appreciate it coming on here
um episode three no no this is yeah
episode three Money Mike I'll see you
later on my man all right see you guys
[Music]